if you know anything about the cost of
space travel the title of this video
might sound like clickbait to you
but if you don't know anything about
space travel the title of this video
might sound like clickbait to you
and to be honest i get it there's just
so much resources being put into
space-faring vessels that it feels like
there's absolutely no way to launch
rockets at zero cost
but if you're elon musk or the people
working at spacex this is not a problem
there are other more important problems
like how to make the tip of their
rockets as pointy as possible so that it
looks cool
maybe we'll address that in another
video but in this video we'll be
discussing how spacex plans to launch
its rockets for free
using a program called rideshare welcome
back to our channel
if you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring that bell
so you're notified every time we upload
a new video the idea of launching
rockets into space at no cost
sounds ridiculous because throughout the
history of space exploration
it has always cost a lot nasa in
particular has not been very
conservative with how much they throw
into the vacuum of space over the years
then spacex came along with its cheaper
rockets but not only are spacex rockets
cheaper to build and launch
they're also reusable fully reusable add
all that together and what you get is
nasa ditching their really expensive
flights and catching the spacex
spaceships to get to space
but these flights also cost something
unlike the spacex rideshare program
which will cost spacex
nothing so what is rideshare well it's
in the name
rideshare is a program that lets several
payloads share a ride into orbit
and this innovation is targeted at the
smallsat industry rocket lab has emerged
as the top operator of this industry
with its electron spaceship
which stands at just 18 meters and 1.2
meters in diameter compared to falcon
9's 63.3 meter height
and 3.7 meter diameter however it
doesn't need to be big because the small
sat industry deals with shipping small
satellites into orbit originally
satellites used to be very big and would
weigh thousands of kilograms however
these big satellites are not necessary
for simple tasks like gathering
scientific data or radio relay
therefore the development of
miniaturized satellites or small sats
weighing below 500 kilograms was
necessary
with further advancement in technology
even smaller satellites called nanosats
that weigh as low as 10 kilograms have
been developed
however a new problem arose and this was
the fact that paying 50 million dollars
the amount for a spacex launch
just to throw an object about the same
weight as three bricks into space
is highly preposterous but with rocket
labs electron flights cost as low
as seven million dollars so it's clear
why they boss the small set market
however spacex has responded in the way
they love to do best because if anyone
knows how to make something as cheap
and affordable as possible it's elon
musk just ask bitcoin traders but
seriously
what they've essentially done is to make
ports available in the payload of their
spaceships like the falcon heavy
where these small satellites can be
attached when they get into low orbit
they're deployed and the work is done
ride share booking is similar to booking
an uber where you can select the desired
orbit
launch date and weight of your payload
and you'll get an immediate estimate of
how much the trip is going to cost you
the cost of a single payload on the
rideshare program is as low
as 1 million there are also costs for
add-ons to consider like a port adapter
a separation system payload electrical
connectivity at the launch pad
fuel for the trip and insurance with
these expenses covered by the owners of
the small sats
spacex is launching these rockets at
zero cost after selecting your choices
you are required to make a
non-refundable reservation deposit that
same day
and the rest of the cost can be covered
in two separate installments
what's even more impressive is that
satellite companies can buy a slot on
the spacex rideshare
program and sublet it to other smaller
cubesat owners for a fraction of the
price as low as 150 thousand dollars
this is common practice for companies
like spaceflight incorporated
and the effect is that the cost of
launching these small sats into orbit is
very cheap for the owners
but spacex gets their money as well when
you consider the fact that the cost of a
lot of falcon 9 flights are cheap due to
their full reusability
it becomes clear that not only are these
launches free but there is also
profit for spacex in this business and
in the past spacex has made use of these
rideshare vehicles to launch its own
starlink satellites
starlink is a low-latency broadband
internet system that serves users around
the globe with high-speed internet with
the use of a constellation of several
satellites
in low earth orbit starlink is the
future of internet connectivity as it
allows you personal access and control
to the internet
even in rural areas although these
satellites are quite powerful
elon musk and companies still manage to
produce them at a cost of 250 thousand
dollars compared to the millions that
other satellites of the same class would
cost
starlink is projected to make up a
constellation of tens of thousands of
these satellites around the earth
seeing as this would cost a lot to
launch fitting it into rideshare
launches with the cost covered by other
satellites is the way to go
and the first rideshare launch had 10
starlink satellites on the ride
but that's not enough and there's only
so much space that can allow for as many
starlink satellites that the company can
squeeze into space for free
and this is where their new spaceship
the starship comes in the starship
vessel completely
obliterates the falcon 9 63 meter height
and 3.7 meter diameter as it stands at
120 meters and has a diameter of 9
meters
this makes the payload bay of the
starship way bigger than the falcon 9.
for comparison the falcon 9 can carry up
to 60 starlink satellites in its payload
bay
whereas the starship rocket will take up
to 240 starlink satellites in its
payload bay easily but it's beyond the
sheer size of the vessel
the starship is not only bigger than any
other space faring vessel ever made but
it also has cheaper launch costs
it costs about 2 million dollars to
launch a starship vessel
this is not only cheaper than the falcon
heavy's 50 million but it's also cheaper
than rocket lab electrons
7 million this is because of the
revolutionary materials used in making
the spaceship
the absence of long-distance
transportation costs due to the factory
testing site and launch pad being in the
same place and of course
the work ethic of elon musk and his team
it's so cheap and easy that spacex can
get these rockets ready for launch
within a week
with a starship vessel the cost for a
port would go from as high as 1 million
dollars in the falcon 9
to as low as just 5 000 and the great
thing is that there will be even more
space to fit in starlink satellites for
free
in the starship than in the falcon 9.
starship may have been built for the
interplanetary exploitation and
colonization of mars
but it definitely has some great
applications in the smallsat market
that will yield economic gains and maybe
unseat rocket lab from its thrown in
this sector
because although the spacex rideshare
program has helped the company enter
into the small sap market they still
face some challenges that rocket lab is
suited to take in their stride
and that challenge is time with the
falcon 9 you have to make sure that
payload for any of the sso
leo and polar orbits are filled up
before takeoff
this means that no matter when you want
to go you'd have to delay your schedule
to meet up with the rest of the
satellites on the payload
this is why the first thing you'll
specify on the website is the orbit you
want and the date you'd want to launch
your rocket
rocket lab has a much smaller rocket for
its own rideshare program
however if it's a matter of urgency they
also have a dedicated program for single
satellite launches for their customers
this costs more than their ride share
program but because the cost to launch
the electron is way cheaper than what
spacex would currently require for their
falcon 9
they currently take the lead on this one
at least for now but we know that
starship launch costs less than the
electron
and so elon musk and his team cannot
wait for the rocket to be fully
functional
so that they blow the competition into
space but what do you think
will rocket lab survive the effect that
starship will have on their small set
market dominance let us know in the
comments below
and if you enjoyed this video make sure
to give it a like and check out more
awesome ones on the simply tech channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time